If you and I both speak the same language,
we can communicate.
If we don't,
we can't.
Right?
Except consider this documentary where they interviewed someone in the sea
islands off Georgia.
He says,
ever since radio and TV came to town,
our way of speaking just became more and more American.
Now we sound like them.
They sound like us.
Just one problem.
This interview has subtitles because America,
this goal is speaker understands you perfectly,
but it's not so easy to go the other way.
See,
sometimes when languages come together,
they create this really odd situation where it's easy enough for one person to
communicate one way,
but it's much harder in reverse.
Today I want to get animated about that,
including one time I noticed it myself and even better three countries full of
people where this kind of asymmetric intelligibility is normal.
Do I finally get to use this one?
I've been sitting on it for a year.
It felt like such a native laying moment,
so I'm in the store standing in line with a hand basket full of what my friend
Javier calls my rabbit food.
I'm agonizing over whether or not to put back the nuts they were on the pricey
side for what you're paying me these days.
Enter a fashionable woman.
She glides over to the fancy tea juice potion section,
the one that's for the $8 plus crowd,
not the five 99 Oh,
isn't that a little pricey for nuts crowd seconds later,
I swear out of nowhere,
one of the employees is right next to her unboxing stuff.
I hear the eagerness in his voice when he asks,
you need help finding anything?
She turns and sounds come out of her mouth,
but no words or wait,
no,
she's speaking Italian are selfless helper doesn't flinch.
He switches from English on the spot.
No momentum lost the to exchange a bit of banter and he shows her down an aisle
and their voices fade into the store.
There's something I forgot to mention though and it's why the moment stuck with
me.
When the employees switched,
he spoke Spanish.
Yeah.
By noon [inaudible] which I find quite lovely.
Two languages.
We're crossing paths,
but in a lopsided way.
He was clearly having an easier time helping her.
Then the other way around.
Why?
Well,
we could come up with reasons he's eager to help.
Maybe he's heard Italian before,
maybe he's used to juggling languages in short motive and opportunity,
but one more factor can come into play in situations like this,
the languages themselves,
to see how,
let's visit a place where this kind of communication happens every day.
This frozen looking area at the top of Europe is home to a bunch of languages,
plus a ton of dialects,
but focus in on the Scandinavian,
north Germanic languages,
Swedish,
Norwegian,
Danish.
For most of us understanding another language takes study and time,
but Scandinavians are lucky.
Their languages are close enough that they can go next door and mostly
communicate semi communication style.
It's like a triangle,
a beautiful triangle of understanding.
This is mutual intelligibility and it is glorious,
but the triangle isn't evenly balanced.
I hear it's much harder to semi communicate in Swedish and Danish than it is in
Swedish and Norwegian,
and it gets even more on equal in each pair.
If you're Danish,
Swedish is easier for you than if you're a Swede hearing Danish.
Hmm.
So unfair.
It's asymmetric intelligibility,
but wow,
that's a lot of syllables.
We could try to boil this down to,
like I said before,
motive and opportunity,
but what if it's not the people but the languages themselves that are creating
Scandinavia as a symmetry?
How could we tell?
Well,
the languages are close enough that their grammar and mostly vocabulary don't
change much from tongue to tongue.
The big difference is in how they get pronounced.
So here's how it's Swedes says,
Copenhagen shopping hum.
And now here's a Dane.
Smart people decided to measure this difference with the live in shooting
distance.
I'm not your math teacher or your math channel,
but here's the function.
If you really want to play with it in it's recursive glory,
I'll honestly be doing the same so we can nerd together,
solidarity,
the results,
estimate what it takes to transform one word into another.
So how far apart cognates should sound Danish cognates should be more distant
from Swedish than the way Norwegian say.
Then Swedish and Danish should be extremes and Norwegians should settle down
right in the middle.
One of those authors teamed up for another study hoping to do even better using
entropy.
Again,
not your math teacher here.
That's my mom's job and she rocks at it.
Basically model the uncertainty Scandinavians feel when they're semi
communicating and guessing.
It sounds an example.
Danish grammatical endings can only have one vowel in them,
but they're Swedish.
Cognates can have three.
This creates uncertainty for Swedes listening to Danish,
so using conditional entropy.
Just how uncertain is Swedish given Danish,
how intelligible is that intelligibility?
Well,
calculating with a bunch of cognates,
it looks like Danish to Swedish should be more complicated,
higher conditional entropy,
then Swedish to Danish.
Swedish and Norwegian are lower,
but we expect more of a challenge going from Norwegian to Swedish than the other
way.
Denmark should understand Norway better than vice versa.
Really?
Danes should get everyone better than they get.
The Danes.
Danish does have a reputation for being tricky one.
We could do a whole animated tangent and danishes very evolved sounds,
but here,
one more time.
Mountain enough said,
so now we have numbers.
Guessing what intelligibility should be.
What happens if we invite real speakers in for a real test?
Ask Scandinavians who use one of the languages at home to listen to a reading in
another language.
Then quiz them.
How well did they understand?
Did high entropy predict low intelligibility?
Let's see.
Danes have an easier time understanding Swedes and vice versa.
Check.
Norwegians and Swedes understand each other better.
Perfect.
Except wait,
why are Norwegian speakers having such an easy time with Danish?
I'm reading that right?
Yeah.
Danish should be hard for no regions,
but these results make it look like Norwegians understand everything better than
everyone.
Why?
Well,
researchers speculate.
I'll have to leave it a mystery this time,
but the reasons probably bring us back to motive and opportunity.
These three factors make intelligibility happened not just in Scandinavia but
around the world.
Written Estonian looks more like finished to fins than written.
Finished does to Estonians Lao and Thai or close,
but you allow speakers out there have a leg up,
possibly thanks to Thai soap operas and magazines,
Jamaican Patois speakers understanding English,
but the reverse isn't it?
Torricelli vaccine and my amazing patrons pointed out Quebec French for per
regions,
Romanian for Italians and Spanish for many kids in the u s so the next time you
can't understand someone who understands you,
it might be because they're motivated.
Maybe they want to help a well-dressed Italian.
It could be exposure.
They've met your words before,
like Gullah,
but most intriguing of all it may be because something about your language tilts
the odds in their favor.
Just because you don't understand someone,
it's no guarantee.
They can't understand you.
Thanks to my patrons for voting for this and for keeping the channels,
heart beating and tongue talking.
Oh,
let me know if you have any asymmetric intelligibility stories of your own.
I'm collecting any good ones and stick around and subscribed for language.